when a woman a woman undergoes
chemotherapy one of the common side
effects is hair loss
well alex wigs can be a quick fix but
what about the long-term effects
especially on
a woman's self-esteem denise valdez has
another option
in our buddy check 8 report
[Music]
you add hair loss to everything else
that a woman is going through and it can
be a real blow to their confidence
but a local artist is working to build
that confidence back
one brushstroke at a time
if the eyes are windows to the soul then
the eyebrows are the frame
see how the lines add up it starts with
mapping the face
mastering the strokes and getting the
color just
right for me to just give them a
beautiful set of eyebrows to make them
wake up every morning like wow i look
good then you know i want to do that
over the past six years khaleesi
garavito has built a successful business
bladed art but her most rewarding
clients
may be the ones who don't pay she was
bald she had
no hair on her eyebrows like nothing so
she was my very first one
after her i was like i have to do this
like all the time garavito chooses a
cancer survivor to donate her work
for free it's an art that i
can give to somebody you know i mean it
doesn't cost me
anything to give to somebody i try to do
it every month so i tell everyone to
email me
story pictures you know their journey
through it through
social media she finds a lucky woman to
transform her face
and give back a little of what they've
lost it's really
touched me as a person and i was like i
really wanted to
like i said it was my first one that
i've ever done and i was like this is it
this is what i want to do and this is
what i want to give
if you know a deserving survivor you can
message bladedart on instagram or her
website
she's looking for next month's recipient
right now
on the eighth of every month we ask
women to call their buddy maybe it's
their mom their sister or friend
and make sure that she's doing her
monthly self breast exam
for buddy check i'm denise valdez